Last night, I was trying to find my brother whose cell phone was dead.
I wish I had a cell phone tracking system.
What is it called, GPS!
This stands for Global Positioning System.
But at the same time, I don't want other people to keep track of my location.
That's totally against privacy,...
...you know, a fundamental human right.
I can't agree with you more.
But if you put it the other way around,...
...the system can be extremely useful.
For instance, when trying to catch a criminal,...
...the system can be very helpful, don't you think?
I'm not too sure how actively it is used today,...
...but we can witness in many movies that the usage of tracking phone systems doesn't appear to be so bad.
I guess the best way would be that there should be a law to enforce limiting any usage for private reasons.
Absolutely.
Like you said, tracking phones could work as a crucial measure,...
...only if used for a criminal investigation.
Otherwise, if the system is widely supplied,...
...the result could be total chaos.
People can't lie about their location,...